great ceremony before the game it was a
great event prior to the game as well
bob euchre celebrated today and uh in
very euchar fashion his ceremonial first
pitch he pops it into a pitching machine
save the arm that's right the guy
through a lot of batting practice in his
uh post playing days corbin burns you
see his numbers that earn running
average good for second best in the
national league he's third in punch outs
but the rest of the mets
it has been a struggle
a swing at a miss
corbin burns drops a big curve ball on
lindor and there is his first strikeout
of the night at 58 strikeouts before he
walked about her a major league record
and he called strike three got a call
that time
and corbin burns with back-to-back case
a one two three first
rich hill right now his 30th start
of the season obviously and his 11th as
a met one relief appearance
and there are his numbers wong at first
stole a base last night
not running and adamus grounds one to
third a chance for two vr tobias and
onto first low throw dug out by alonzo
and they turn the double play
five four three to get hilda's first two
out
vr on the ground backhanded wong jump
throw
how about that play
gold glove second baseman colt wong
showing that gold glove form right there
and two strikes on manny pena
the stretching here it comes
swing a fly ball hit to shallow left
charging hard in left and making the
catches mcneil no opportunity for yellow
to try and tag and score again the o2
and that curveball on the outside corner
for strike three call for a promising
start to the inning the brewers
strand the bases loaded
one and two the count on mccann a swing
at a miss he struck him out
got him with a curveball
strikeout number three for corbin burns
2-2
on the ground
adamus winds it up fires and escobar
makes a play
oh
what a pick by eduardo escobar
and rich hill who just put the ball in
play
has a hit taken away from him the last
two innings
we have had a couple of gems by the
brewer defenders so two on now and one
away for christian yelich who had the
great night last night
bill kicks delivers and yell it's a
tapper out in front of the mound hill
off the mount fields underhand toss
takes care of yelich
both runners move up 90 feet
escobar was hit by a pitch as last time
up
another 2-2 and that one's in the left
field a base hit escobar a pump of the
fist
garcia coming home he'll score two runs
are in eduardo escobar
a two out two strike two rbi single
nimble lines one the other way and he
won't retire 18 in a row tonight that's
of their first base runner an opposite
field single for nemo one of the games
premier shortstops
owen to the count nimmo the runner at
first long pause by burns
and a swing he had a miss he got him
runner goes
throw to second on the mark the tag he
is out at second base oh what a throw by
manny pina perfect throw
adam has let it travel look at this
aggressive tag here
so two on it nobody on want to know to
conforto
he slashes one the other way and that's
a base hit for michael
they'll go for two and make it easily as
the ball kicks away from yelich and
conforto's got himself an opposite field
double
he has been very good over the course of
the last month for new york
can silence those boos
with a big hit here for the mets
and he rips one into left field base hit
conforto will score easily down to
second on the play goes alonzo and
aboard with an rbi single javier baez
metz on the board it's now 2-1 milwaukee
got him
did he go he did
a strikeout vr's gone on a big cutter
from corbin burns
picks up his fifth cave but the mets do
score burns is mad at himself
pitch to mccann line drive caught
third baseman luisa is there to snag it
[Applause]
1-1 pitch and he tries to bunt gets it
down
and burns is not going to get there in
time he throws it down the right field
line hill is not going to advance to
second he'll take it back to the bag but
that's a beautiful play by rich hill a
beautiful bunt drop down oh i love it so
much because he deserved the single from
the last ap and he drops a little bunt
that doesn't go anywhere lands uh just
in the cut of the grass
metz with back-to-back hits with two
outs
and shane had a miss he struck him out
and the inning is over corbin burns
picks up number five here's avi garcia
he has struck out and drawn a walk
out of his hand by not even throwing a
strike
well he threw that one right down the
middle to get him looking so you just
never know right caught him looking for
a curve seven in a row retired by
hillary struck out six over five innings
tonight mets down two to one going to
the sixth
one two coming
lined in the left yelich coming on
yelling nice sliding catch he hangs on
two away
one and two on javi baez
the kick and pitch
struck him out with a hammer of a
curveball
bae is gone matt's finished in the sixth
so the brewers got something started
here with one away
two on
and here comes tyrone taylor
02 from loop
rounded towards short chance for two
lindora tobias good pick up throw to
first in time for the double play
and with that aaron loop cra goes under
one for the season
he gets the double play ball to keep it
a two to one game
drifting into that uh 100 pitch
territory
here's one two
got him
nasty curveball from burns
and vr is strikeout victim number eight
two two the count
will most certainly be the last inning
for burns
and hoping this is his last hitter
burns kicks through the pitch swinging a
miss he struck him out with a curve ball
burns with his ninth strikeout of the
night
and seven innings of one run baseball
from corbin burns here against the met
three and one to pina
and he drives one to left center field
cutting across his nipple diving and he
made the catch
beautifully done by nimmo whose arm got
tucked underneath him
but i think he's okay jackie bradley
junior's going to run for vogelback
one out bottom seven brewers with a
runner on
with wong at the plate the brewers would
love to
put some runs on the board
and that'll
get it done base head cold wong
bradley the second shift was on wong
took the humble approach
02 from may and garcia goes down
swinging to end the inning nicely done
so trevor may strands a couple keeps it
two to one going to the eighth
33 year old brad boxberger in his first
year in milwaukee he was with the
marlins last year and slashed by nimmo
through the hole and he's got his third
hit of the night oh you've got three
hits
to left field
and they still leaving the short stops
hole open for him
well it's a high fastball
one ball two strikes a count
and he got him put it right there that's
a good spot for it right there
josh hayder trying to close it down
tonight his only blown save of the year
came against the mets in july
3-2 pitch and alonso on the ground nice
play
willie and david still first in time
they ate him up inside with a fastball
good pitch
avi baez
responsible for the lone mets run
first ball swinging
adama's got to wind it up he fires in
time two outs
the funky mechanics that make him very
tough to hit but he's got great command
with that crossfire delivery into the
count
and he missed badly so hader
a little amped up and he walks vr as
peraza will bat in a pinch hit
appearance for jeff mcneal and maybe
hater looking to get a little bit of
redemption after peraza took him deep
for his only blown save hater deals
did he go he did
struck him out to end the game
josh hader closes the door on the mets
you